you from my upbeat instagram videos and
the word conservatorship
basically i started this show oops you
did it again
so people could come on and apologize
for things they've done wrong
because after the free britney
documentary came out i'm receiving
hundreds of apologies a day the new
documentary framing britney spears takes
a look at the pop star
and her struggles with mental health
financial freedom
and misogyny it highlights the singer's
legal battles with her father's father
specifically the conservatorship
she has been under for more than a
decade but it also puts a harsh
spotlight on the problem of misogyny
in the media even coming from some
unexpected sources
i have to ask a couple of things about
justin okay
of course he's going on television
and pretty much said you broke his heart
you did something that caused him so
much pain
so much suffering what did you do
the documentary looks at how the media
has covered brittany from the fir
from the time she first stormed onto the
music scene in 1999
and it shows us who we are as a culture
and how far we've come over the past two
decades
and how we treat women but the evolution
hasn't been easy at all
it's happened in part because of the
activism of
feminists and the moment of reckoning
after the downfall of harvey weinstein
and bill cosby to the rise of president
donald trump
but we still have a long damn way to go
my next guest is one of my favorite
actors and activists
and one of the people that i most wanted
to talk to about this documentary
and misogyny in the media and joining me
now is jamila
jamil jamila it's so great to see you
thank you so much for taking the time
um hello um what was your
initial reaction oh [ __ ] i'm
sorry god thank you
no there's a there's a slight delay no
no don't worry
there's a slight delay and i will adjust
for the delay
so first question is just what was your
first reaction
to the documentary you've been on the
free britney train for
years now you've been on this tip for a
minute
i think i've generally been on the tip
uh for years you know i've been in this
industry for 12 years and so
i've known for ages and i've watched so
many so many women rise and fall
i've known for ages that me too isn't
where misogyny starts
and ends in the industry that sexual
harassment isn't the only form
that misogyny takes within this industry
and that there is a more pervasive and
insidious form of misogyny that
so many of us fall victim to where the
media has this kind of perfect
uh template for taking a woman just
choosing a woman
who is standing out or speaking out in
this industry
uh bringing her up and building her up
and hyperbolizing how amazing she is
over exposing her to the point where the
public then becomes sick of her
the public starts to think that she
herself is uh
you know she herself believes these uh
hyperbolized
versions of her that the media keep
putting out and so once the public is
sick of this woman
who has just been overexposed and
pummeled at them you know almost to
death
uh the the media then knows that that
woman
is primed for a takedown via smear
campaigns
or via rumors or accusations
often that they pluck out thin air from
a source or
you know a family friend etc and we
watched this time and time again and i
think
this britney documentary is probably
just the first time in ages
that we can no longer be gaslit about
the fact that we definitely do this much
more so to women the things that we
punish
and and persecute women over are so much
harsher than the things that
the things that a man would have to do
in order to get into as much trouble as
a woman
it just goes beyond belief look at the
things that shia labeouf has been
accused of look at the things that casey
affleck all of the people throughout me
too
army hammer etc the things that cause a
man to fall into disgrace publicly
the bar is set so much higher for their
cancellation
than it is for women a woman just has to
smile the wrong way in order for us
to decide that we're done with her we're
going to cast her out
into the shadows and so i think the
britney documentary was just
really important in highlighting a
how poorly we understand mental health
and how poorly we treat those who are
struggling with their mental health
but mostly how vile and violent we are
towards young women in media
you mentioned gaslighting and i love
that you use that term
because you've been talking about
gaslighting um for for many many years
but i think it's a term people
just became familiar with if they
weren't reading feminist blogs
um because of donald trump because what
he did every day
was essentially try to tell us you know
up was down and down was up like he
tried to change how we really
saw what was happening around us um why
do you think
gaslighting is such a dangerous thing
and in need of being called out
every single time particularly when it
comes to young people
i mean look that that's a whole big old
conversation and there are people far
smarter and more educated than me to
take that on but i think in the context
of this specific conversation
the reason this is so important is that
if we keep being convinced
that this isn't real that women aren't
being persecuted so much more so and
more regularly than men in this kind of
pattern of build her up specifically to
tear her down
throw her onto a pedestal that she did
not herself climb onto
and that pedestal turns out to actually
be a trap door into a gutter in which we
just shame her
and you know essentially flog her
publicly
we're never going to be able to unpick
this pattern and undo this pattern and
and overturn this system of our
oppression
and our global humiliation and
because they've managed to keep us apart
and keep us silent for such a long time
we've each had these individual
experiences
of of being humiliated publicly picked
up and then
thrown to the ground and thought that it
was our fault we were told all this time
that it was in our head
it was our fault and if we complained
about it that we were just moaning and
we were complaining
and the importance of us coming together
as one
comparing our circumstances in and and
talking about these things and coming
out and making these documentaries and
calling this stuff out when we see it
helps us recognize that these individual
experiences are actually
one in the same there is a it's a
well-oiled machine it's a perfect
template
uh that has been used for since the
beginning of time if you take it all the
way back to the garden of eden
you know it was eve's fault we have
shamed and blamed
women from the start and so this
narrative
has got to come to an end and it's only
going to come to an end if we call it
out every time we see it we have such a
peculiar attitude towards women in this
industry when we don't like a man
i feel like we just don't learn his name
and we don't follow him on social media
and we generally just don't acknowledge
his existence
but when we don't like a woman we will
follow her we will hate to follow her
we will read every bad article about her
we will learn everything we can we will
go back through her twitter 10 12 years
we will try to justify this hatred that
we have of her
we have a peculiar and deeply misogynist
culture towards women and i think women
participate in it i know i have
in the past and i also know that i have
disliked women based on tabloid media
articles and just headlines and
photographs in the past
where i've never bothered to go to
source and now all i'm urging people to
do
is to go to source you know we all
listen to justin timberlake's version of
what happened
what a mistake well it seems to me yeah
exactly right um and it also feels like
we just have to have these conversations
more um because it's it the only way we
actually can grow
is if we confront our shortcomings and
one of the ways i think that you're
helping us do that
is you started a whole organization
called iway it's it's a whole
community it has a podcast um and it's
it's really a community i mean everybody
should check it out
why did you want to start this um with
the sort of central idea
that it is all about radical inclusivity
i mean you touch on
on weight and and body image but also
mental health it's so many different
things but it's
all based on this premise of sort of
radical inclusivity what does that mean
and why did you start
start this community well as the saying
goes if you can't
see it you can't be it and i'm someone
who grew up never seeing south asians in
positions of prominence in media
or in politics and so therefore i
remember the damage that did to me how
much it made me want to distance myself
from my culture
and align myself to whatever i could see
on the television
rather than just be who i was and i
inherently didn't
think that any of these things could
ever be for me
and so i am determined to use the
fairly large platform i have uh i'm
certainly not like a
you know huge global icon or anything
like that but i have
several million followers and i want to
use that platform to highlight
as big as as big and as diverse
uh a community of people as i can and
all these different communities and i
you know i want to learn about them and
i don't ever profess to be an expert on
anything
i want to learn about them with my
community it's an allyship community
it's a place where we're not going to
shame you for what you don't already
know
we're just so excited that you're here
and ready to learn so we have a youtube
channel we have a podcast
and we bring on experts and activists
and artists from
every different gender or race or
background or age group
to to educate us on how we can
better support one another as a group
rather than a lot of the
you know in particular we see this and
with the left and with liberals
a lot of the self-cannibalizing and
infighting that's happening that is
allowing us to distract each other while
our oppressors
laugh at us and just carry on on their
path
to successful oppression so we're trying
to just
organize mobilize and support those who
are on the ground
uh risking their lives in order to fight
historic systems of oppression and this
is just
the way that i've currently found to
effectively reach millions of people at
a time with
as much helpful information as i can
gather and we learn at the same time and
i'm trying to be a public role model for
learning and for making learning okay
and for making
failure okay and for being to be okay if
you're a woman who makes a mistake
you're allowed to
come back and do better this idea that
men
can self-improve and be congratulated
upon their journey
of self-improvement but if a woman makes
a mistake because we hold her to this
impossible standard
she must be uh removed from society
forever
it's just nonsense and so that's what
i'm trying to do with iway it's
it's a shameless space where we're just
all about trying to
you know i was on a show called the good
place on nbc for years and
our motto was just try to be better
tomorrow than you were today
and i think that that's definitely the
message of
of i way which is progress not
perfection and just trying to make
people feel seen heard and included
it's so important because nobody can be
perfect like absolutely zero people
are perfect and never make mistakes and
if anybody is putting themselves out as
somebody who is better than other people
and never makes mistakes they are lying
um so i appreciate your honesty because
i am the same way like i am the first
one to tell you like
i'm mean sometimes i'm grumpy sometimes
i'm crabby in the morning
before caffeine like i'm judgey like i'm
working on these things i'm a human
being and so are you
and so we're just gonna learn and grow
together i'm so
thankful to you for taking the time out
of your busy day to have this
conversation
um it's really important jamila jamil
everybody check out her i way community
thank you so much for being here
tonight and please stay safe
hi i'm zerlina maxwell thanks for
checking out our channel on youtube
you can see more from zerlina by
clicking any of the videos on this
screen
and make sure you subscribe below to
stay up to date on the day's biggest
stories
thanks for watching